[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans six ans
par les sports comme vous pouvez le voir
nous sommes sur notre 31 pour cette
émission de fin d'année cinq
chroniqueurs sont autour de cette table
pour m'accompagner à présentation on
commence à ma droite on va passer une
heure avec un champion du monde de
cyclisme sur piste
comme d'habitude il est habillé de façon
très élégante le capitaine y est déjà
rieppi star au pub de vélizy 78 kg
mickaël comment t'as le look super
endroit 31
aujourd'hui oui oui jamais de jamais de
cravate ou de papillons par entre autres
pour cette émission est très vous avez
toujours prêt comme 2000 comme toujours
alors on passe de l'autre côté musique
c'est un petit nouveau dans l'équipe ce
passionné de football et notamment fans
du club de saint-etienne il fait
également du handball en fauteuil à
montigny le bretonneux et vous allez
voir le voir il a beaucoup d'humour
stéphane de visée est avec nous bonsoir
michael savoir comment avez-vous bon pas
top pour eux c'est les fins d'années moi
mais bon pas plus que ça envoie aussi
d'aller mieux
ok on avait un petit message dans votre
dos oui je sais pas si on peut le revoir
mais chez handicapés êtes gentil quand
même oui bien sûr on va voir son
émission aucun problème en passe de
l'autre côté à musica nous vient tout
droit de versailles
elle aussi s'est habillée sur son 31
pour cette émission elle est venue elle
est aussi envoûtante que pertinente sur
ses réponses
hélène de la grange notre ambassadrice
de charme et à je suis ravie d'être de
nouveau là une nouvelle tête un père
noël c'est fabuleux
quant au chant mais en fait je suis sûr
qu'il est pas méchant mais je vais très
bien vous avez très chiant mais est très
bien parfait on passe de l'autre côté
c'est notre zorro illinois pendant les
fêtes qui va chercher dans les prairies
du département
smoking vous le croiserez peut-être du
côté de plaisir waouh cottrez d'autres
et est avec nous comment allez-vous la
rouille kinois comme d'habitude je vais
très bien et vous alors du coup c'est
une des gens n'ont pas de vous voir vous
chevauchez dans les prairies signe des
gens assez assez régulière ça c'est
régulier tous les week-ends avec mes
chevaux tous les jours à côté de plaisir
pour les admiratrices
on termine de l'autre côté à musique on
aimerait également trinqué avec lui le
31 au soir c'est un véritable gentleman
toujours aussi élégant mais il n'hésite
pas à aller au combat on surnomme dans
cette émission le gladiateur pierre
chevalier du rugby-club de versailles
est avec nous pendant une heure salut
michael c'est lui copains
vous avez sorti la cravate rouge pour
l'occasion au pot où le père noël rouge
et blanc deux circonstances
alors avant de passer au titre de cette
émission on commence par une info qui
est encore à prendre avec des pincettes
le vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines serait en
négociations avancées pour organiser une
rencontre de première division liga
le match se déroulerait courant mars
avril dans la structure le dossier
serait en phase de finalisation et
pourrait concerner deux équipes de haut
de tableau on parle de tours et de paris
l'officialisation devrait intervenir
courant janvier
est ce que c'est une bonne idée vous
votez autour de cette table
oui oui oui un maillage avis qui est
partagé sur wii passe tractations le
tout problème c'est qu'à chaque fois
qu'il ya des événements comme ceux-là
qui sont organisés ben faut pas porter
faut pas oublier une chose c'est que
nous les cyclistes
on ne peut plus rouler sur notre beau
vélodrome donc bien sûr que c'est très
bien parce qu'ils s'affairent permet de
faire vivre le vélodrome et ça permet de
donner une vraie belle activité de le
remplir et de et de verdi de voir de
belles affiches parce que là on a deux
belles équipes de
de première division mais voilà le
revers de la médaille c'est qu'on peut
plus et qu'on peut pratiquer le vélo
pendant un week-end par exemple
voilà donc donc oui c'est bien mais
dommage pour nous du côté du petit côté
égoïste voilà raul
qu'est ce que vous en pensez alors mon
retour je pense que pour le vélodrome
c'est une corde de plus à son arc et que
ça permet aussi justement de le
rentabiliser
et de le faire vivre donc je suis
favorable mais je suis sûr que pierre
est quelque part favorable aussi yann
pardon favorable à ça aussi mais qu' il
a un avis un petit peu subjectif sur la
chose pierre justement alors vous vous
êtes favorable à 100% vous a vu dégainer
comme d'habitude et on en parle
suffisamment ici faut que ces enceintes
vive et que et que le territoire sportif
et toutes les enceintes sportives des
yvelines puisse vivre
on dit souvent souvent sur ce plateau
que le vélo ne fait pas suffisamment
recettes en dehors des pratiquants bien
évidemment mais n'apporte pas assez de
spectateurs au vélodrome il ya la
perspective jeux olympiques il ya eu il
ya eu d'autres événements et d'autres
sports qui ont pris compris cette
enceinte et il ya un match de volley de
première division c'est une
c'est une très bonne idée pour notre
équipe normalement ça des tours et
détours et parisse est décédé très
belles affiches j'irai voir pour
soutenir mais mon ma ville d'origine de
tours et ça fait du spectacle en plus
des spurs plus donc c'est très bien pour
nous aller prendre votre votre place
c'est ce que j'irai prendre ma place ici
c'est paris et tours j réagirait
supporter tour au vélo je crois de
permettre aux gens de connaître le
volley ball les yvelinois qui n'ont pas
qu'ils ne peuvent pas aller sur paris
pour voir des gros matches ça leur
permet aussi de voir au vélodrome des
gros match dans quinze ans plus les
niveaux milliard joue pourtant oui
proche de paris mais il joue pourtant
sur le paris ouest et pas très loin du
parc des princes de mémoire ram et les
matchs de volley ball généralement donc
c'est quand même facile d'accès c'est
toutefois se déplacer ou pour rester
voir un match de haut niveau
ce serait se sont très bien j'espère que
je ne dois me rappela moelleux
ce que j'aime c'est de voir plein alors
il a été plein justement il ya déjà
rallié 1 2 fois c'était pour du handball
hélène deux fois où le club d'issy paris
qui est devenu le club paris 92 à queue
à organiser deux matches au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines deux fois ça
fait cliché fermé mais il faut de toute
façon c'est ce que disait fier c'est en
2017 et 2018 à j'allais dire les années
en vue donc 2018 mais les les enceintes
comme ça il faut qu'ils aient des
matches à l'intérieur il faut partager
vraiment toute façon c'est une scène
comme on dirait un événement qui va
durer combien de temps ça va être assez
bref il ya des prêts par des préparatifs
évidemment mais de mémoire je crois que
ça avait fait fermer le vélothon pendant
une semaine à peu près d'eux pour
l'heure nous allons manquer à moins que
ça même un peu moins en me jurant là
heureusement la chebba qui se veut venir
s'entraîner mais voilà oui et je sais
que les organisateurs sur le vélodrome
font le nécessaire pour que l'on puisse
venir s'entraîner deux maximum voilà ce
soit pas que ce soit pas gênant mais
après j'ai dis ça juste pour défendre
défendre le vélo et elle est bien sûr un
baiser de france des gens comme disait
jean je suis
je suis très contente de bouts événement
/ / semaine
mais voilà je défends toujours mon sport
et j'aimerais qu'il y ait plus
d'événements un cycliste et qu'il y ait
plus d'événements cyclistes qui fasse
venir du monde
c'est ça le ce serait ça le l'idéal mais
aujourd'hui on n'y arrive pas
malheureusement alors nous allons
maintenant passer au programme de
l'émission aujourd'hui nous allons
parler de l'un des événements de cette
fin d'année l'ancien footballeur du
paris saint-germain pauleta est venu en
séance de dédicaces à montigny le
bretonneux
nous ferons également un coup de
projecteur sur les tops et les flops de
l'année 2019 dans le département vous ne
manquerez aucun moment fort mais avant
mais avant de développer ces thèmes
on va parler à football au football les
versaillais connaissent désormais leurs
adversaires pour les êtres 32e de finale
de la coupe de france et joueur de
youssef chili pensionnaire de nationale
3 vont recevoir à domicile granville une
équipe de nationale 2 un tirage
abordable pour le club qui n'a plus
connu ce stade de la compétition depuis
dix ans la rencontre sera programmée le
samedi 4 janvier à 13h au stade mob
auront la question sur ce thème faut-il
être déçu de ce tirage c'est une équipe
de nationale 2 1 je le rappelle
granville parce que vous êtes déçu oui
non feinte petit duel entre wust et pas
les pierres stéphane bienvenus oui déçu
parce que ça aurait pu être l'occasion
pour versailles de de jouer contre un
très grand club comme le paris saint
germain ou marseille
et puis mon granville c'est ils ont
quand même une fois fait un gros coup
en france je crois contre marseille et
moi je pense que c'est une équipe qui va
régulièrement loin de france un oui oui
oui j'ai mal je les avais vus éliminer
contre marseille je crois pas trop te
dire ça ça peut vous énerver un petit
peu de noms mais je pense qu'il aurait
pu y avoir un club de liga qui aurait pu
venir à versailles le psg qui affrontera
lca volery juste à côté en essonne l'as
saint-etienne 10e je dis rien par
exemple pierre chevallier s'est d'abord
dit non parce que sportivement ça va
alors permettre peut-être même s'ils ont
envie est une équipe une équipe a
redouté mais ça va leur permettre de
passer un tour de plus donc passer un
tour de plus justes sont frottés se
frottait un plus grand c'est vrai que là
on a l'habitude dans l'enclos front
d'avoir d'avoir cette magie cette magie
des petits qu'ils rencontrent l'hérault
mais mais là avec avec un plat un peu
plus abordable
on peut peut-être espérer se voir ce
devoir passer ce tour est d'aller juste
derrière se frotter à un gros
effectivement s'il ne passe pas ce
tour-là la wii a posteriori on voir être
déçu de la fiche de la fiche des 32e
mais mais on peut simplement dire que
versailles qui a mal pas mal en ce
moment est plutôt le vent en poupe peu
peut se peut passer ce tour et battre
baie de granville justement pour aller
chercher un chat ils sont d'ailleurs co
leader je crois avec lui je pense que
c'est c'est une bonne année pour pour
passer quelques tours même si il ya une
seule division d'écart la fiche ne fait
pas forcément autant rêver que les
détours que les tours contre les gros et
justement accordons mettons une pièce
sur sur le sur la victoire de versailles
est justement
terrain gros en seizièmes boire en
huitièmes ces jeunes alors pierre
chevalier 1 j'ai noté un votre pronostic
il y aura un petit pari sûrement qui va
s'effectuer à vous au moins 106
personnes
le 4 janvier c'est débile
justement qu'est ce que vous en pensez
alors vous êtes plutôt de l'avis de
pierre chevalier c'est un effet on
pourra seulement être déçus s'ils ne
passent pas le ce tour la voilà
aujourd'hui bon bah tant mieux c'est une
opportunité mais si si ça se passe si ça
se passe mal
ben c'est dommage d'avoir fait un déjà
très beau parcours
parce que parce que voilà d'aller de
recommencer enfin d'arriver au moment où
on peut commencer à rencontrer les gros
c'est pas du tout ce qu'on fait tous les
ans mais dommage de ne pas avoir cette
opportunité
après ben si ça se fait un tour plus
tard tant mieux parce que ben les ça
permettra aussi de faire entrer de
l'argent dans les caisses du club et ça
c'est pas non plus négligeable de
pouvoir le faire
après six mois ce que je leur souhaite
c'est de vraiment rencontré un gros et
de pouvoir aller jouer dans une enceinte
elle peut être que le parc des princes
où mon pas le stade de france mais
d'aller jouer au parc des princes ce
serait quand même une très très belle
très belle chose parce que l'expérience
qui pourrait vivre serait juste magique
voilà justement lors de la dernière
campagne de versailles en coupe de
france il avait déjà perdu en contre en
32e de finale n'avait perdu la dernière
fois il avait perdu contre dijon sur le
score de 5 buts à 1 c'était pas
forcément le gros match mais il avait
perdu 1 raul ce match là moi je n'ai pas
vu finalement il faut peut-être se
trouve être affronté des équipes un peu
plus faible moi je pense que de toute
façon que ce soit par prestige ou par
l'évolution son championnat c'est comme
entrer en deuxième en 32e avec une
petite équipe c'est quand même plus
favorable quitte à ce que les gros match
arrive vers la fin et a contrario ça
permet peut-être aussi à granville de
créer l'exploit d'arriver en huitièmes
donc je trouve que c'est un tirage idéal
pour les deux équipes alors justement là
une dernière vous l'avais dit il ya déjà
riez lens avait battu cette équipe de
versa une équipe c'était une équipe de
ligue 2 qui avait battu versailles 4 à 2
mais le meilleur résultat de l'histoire
du club
c'était en 16e de finale en 1948
il avait perdu 4 à 1 face à gueugnon
donc 16e de finale si pas ce taux ils
arriveront à leur meilleur niveau
historique dans cette compétition est-ce
que ça va pas créer justement un peu
trop de pression à votre avis hélène je
veux marquer l'histoire du club
oui justement ça c'est la source de
motivation oui puis la ccc loin dans le
temps le match et tout de suite là il
est je pense qu'ils ont autre chose à
faire qu'à se mettre la pression de
match de 1942 et autres jeux les
cassettes vhs quand on regarde le match
de l'année dernière contre une équipe de
ligue 2 ça donne toute la magie de la
coupe de france contre des gros et plus
gros et surtout des équipes historiques
les sang et or à mont boron ça c'est
quelque chose qui reste dans les images
dans les images de tv 78 notamment et et
dans l'est dans les têtes dé versailles
et maintenant il y avait deux dehors
voilà c'était en plus accroché et la
goutte du la coupe de france est une
compétition complètement à part on a
l'impression rebate les câpres alors je
garde à chaque match et les différences
les différences de division s'estompe
donc la nacion nationale 3 nationale 2
c'est c'est vraiment sur le papillon
premier ex-aequo on le disait
injustement stéphane ya plus de national
avec un bilan de huit victoires un nul
et deux défaites depuis le début de la
saison mais ils ont un match en moins
donc en gros il pourrait être premier
c'est encore ce match en moins et
granville et sixième de son championnat
route de mazères année ou jamais pour
passer ce cap là il va notamment poissy
la leçon record et qui on verra on verra
si ça si ça passe aussi par une grosse
affiche contre un euro mais à quelque
chose c'est
qu'on peut dire c'est qu'actuellement
versailles ils ont un attaquant qui a le
vent en poupe akassou du guanacaste
voilà oui qui est pisté par des clubs de
ligue 1 dont lens nantes amiens et je
pense qu'il va y va se savoir regarder
et ça ça peut aider à versailles ça sera
l'occasion de se montrer
je pense que la coupe de france c'est le
cas du rasage et occasion c'est une
occasion les ddd club petit poucet qui
ont qui ont réalisé qu on tue les faits
lui ont fait plusieurs fois belle parmi
les entraîneurs ont pu accéder à des
plus grandes et des plus grands plus
grands clubs et puis il ya eu des belles
histoires avec des avec des avec des
foulards aussi la solution c'est que les
plus petites équipes sur le papier font
jouer leur équipe forte et que les clubs
les clubs mieux classés ou ou des
divisions supérieures
généralement profite pour faire tourner
sauf si la coupe de france est un des
objectifs sportifs de la saison et va se
savoir regardez donc il va te donner
c'est l'occasion pour lui de monter de
six divisions au dessus en tout cas vous
avez bien poster vos fiches tant que
nouveau alors c'est pas le cas de tout
le monde ici autour de cette table en
scène ses 15 buts en coupe de france et
championnat
vous êtes obligés de bosser en soit ces
missions fayotage années cool d'avoir
continué à parler un football il est
arrivé telle une rock star à montigny le
bretonneux pedro miguel pauleta ancien
attaquant du paris saint germain
de 2003 à 2008 est venue en séance
dédicace dans cette grande surface
l'occasion pour l'aigle des açores au
109 buts avec le pg de retrouver ses
fans
on écoute sa réaction au micro de tv 78
c'est un plaisir regardez tout ce retard
et c'est à côté de moi c'est un serial
italienne que ça continue depuis deux
ans 11 12 ans venus comme ambassadeur
d'une grande marque de café portugais il
a signé des autographes et pris des
photos pendant plus d'une heure avec 600
supporters présents certains n'ont pas
hésité à partir plus tôt du travail et à
patienter dans la longue file d'attenté
super important quand on voit le joueur
emblématique était pauleta bouarbi
supporters du psg c'est normal de venir
à cette séance de dédicaces ça fait du
monde pour un jour où 16 heures comme ça
où les gens travaillent
mais je pense que certains se libère
comme en l'occurrence mais bon une fois
dans notre vie après c'est un sacré
souvenir
ça vous surprend cet engouement pour
pauleta raul je pense que pour les
personnes qui sont intrinsèquement
passionné par le football et par le club
il a plus marqué les esprits parce que
si je prends l'exemple par exemple de
zlatan ibrahimovic
c'était lui et le psg à côté mais
c'était une personne à part entière et
qui générait une attraction autour de
lui alors que pauleta il était vraiment
en rouge et bleu se trouve que il s'est
imprégné beaucoup il est vraiment plus
dans la dynamique psg c'est plus
imprégnés de cette équipe il a vraiment
revêtir le maillot donc ça m'étonne pas
la question sur cette thématique pauleta
et il la vraie légende du psg oui ou non
on voit où l'enfant l'a compris un nom
vous êtes partagés ont fait un petit
duel entre le retour le match photo
entre pierre chevallier et stéphane
décidément avec pierre vous commencez à
cette fois-ci là c'est la question de la
légende du psg ils sont ces décès des
équipes de des onze majeur qui se sont
succédé depuis des années et des années
pour l'instant sans ligue des champions
mais avec avec un certain nombre de
titres au poste d'attaquant je
rejoindrai ce que dit ce que disait raul
c'est un c'est un joueur qui a marqué le
cas marqué le club sportivement en
termes de performances et de et de buts
marqués mais surtout humainement et les
vrais supporters du psg s'y sont pas
trompés et c'est pour ça qu'ils ont
massivement répondu présent quand quand
par l'état organise une séance anodine
de
de dédicaces ou de signatures
d'autographes quant à dire de là à dire
que c'est la légende du psg c'est une
des nombreuses légendes du psg en
attaque on à la tonalité cité on a eu il
ya giorgio et à sur les grandes années
les valdo les ricardo tout là tout là
toute la galaxie des brésiliens du psg
et ginola
bravo ils ont ils ont tous marqué le
club
de là à sortir une légende il ya
quelqu'un qui aurait vraiment été au
dessus de la tête et des épaules pendant
toutes ces saisons c'est c'est un petit
peu je pense un petit peu difficile ou
prématurée il faut simplement dire que
pauleta malgré tout a duré et il dure
encore dans le coeur des dans le coeur
des coeurs des supporters parisiens donc
c'est pas la légende du psg mais c'est
une des nombreuses légendes et notamment
notamment une vraie personnalité
non je veux dire non pas l'auteur en
l'état c'est pas la légende mais c'est
l'une des légendes
enfin je voudrais dire c'est chaque
génération psg il ya sa légende je veux
dire il ya une carlos bianchi
il ya eu ardiles s il ya une aînée
ronaldinho et ibrahimovic pauleta avant
maintenant il ya mba picardie et tout ça
moi je veux dire à chaque époque il ya
un joueur qui sort du lot mais il n'ya
pas encore ce footballeur qui est au
dessus de tout y'a pas et ça aurait été
vraiment la légende si ils avaient
permis par exemple au psg de gagner des
champions ce qui sera peut-être le cas
de rang
deux coupes de france avec le psg
c'était une honte de voir s'il ya des
juges arrière voilà de coupe de france
c'était en 2004 et 2007 et une fois et
bordeaux également en 2002 déjà et qui
vous attend un cliff moi je suis
d'accord avec eux je suis d'accord ce
que tout est dit c'est ça c'est ça il
n'y avait rien à rajouter
tout est tout à fait à vie et personne
ne peut enfin parce qu'aujourd'hui
originalement c'est le nombre de buts
peut-être qui compte ce camp là on le
voit il est quasiment à un but tous les
deux matches au psg
est ce que c'est le nombre de buts qu'il
a fait rentrer dans nos coeurs des
supporteurs mais aujourd'hui enfin dans
après ça il faut pas oublier une chose
c'est que aujourd'hui il ya des très
bons joueurs qui jouent au club de paris
et on en parle plus quand les joueurs ne
sont plus là que de voirie sont encore
c'est à dire que l'on pourra comparer à
partir du moment où les joueurs qui sont
aujourd'hui à paris seront partis pour
moi edison cannes à l'unisson pour moi
edison cavani aujourd'hui c'est quand
même un joueur qui a énormément fait et
qui fait énormément pour l'ozone 66 buts
et est donc déjà meilleur buteur de
l'histoire du club
eh ben ce jour là on ne peut pas
l'oublier et je suis désolé quand il ne
sera plus au parc est un jeu comme ça +
ac au psg je sais très bien qu'il sera
dans les coeurs des parisiens c'est
normal parce que c'est un joueur qui
sait aussi imprégné du maillot donc on
peut pas les comparer et les époques
font que chacun enfin voilà pour moi si
je devais sortir un joueur et fut pas
supporters de de paris mais genre jouer
voilà c'est quand même le joueur il a
été ballon d'or
peut-être pas quand il était à paris je
me souviens pas mais il est vrai que c
est donc le et donc du coup si on doit
sortir un joueur de du psg pour moi
c'est voilà ce gala il a été il a joué à
paris et il a été ballon d'or ensuite
voilà c'est quand même quelque chose de
2,2 et puis il y en a un qu'on n'a pas
cités il ya aussi rail qui n'étaient pas
sains qui n'était pas l'attaquant qui
était plus un distributeur mais rails
c'est pareil c'est quelqu'un qui
quelques allées c'est une vraie
empreinte dans ce club et aujourd'hui on
sait très bien qu'ils aient encore
parise à mon coeur et ma paie par
exemple qui a déjà 71 buts avec le psg
est-ce qu'il peut dépasser 1 pauleta
dans le coeur des supporteurs les on dit
oui non mais ça et puis il est entre
guillemets en début de carrière il a
largement retombé
le gros avantage que quelques quillanais
de bpa c'est que dans tous les noms
qu'on a cité c'est peut-être le seul
français est le seul vrai parisien il
est quand même originaire d'île de
france
donc du coup il peut avoir un supplément
d'âme par rapport à tous ces joueurs
restent à partir ça va rien venir je
suis c'est ce que je souhaite c'est sur
ces choix 70 buts ont obtenu durant ces
vingt trois saisons kazim kazim en
doublant
doublant ça fait trois saisons de plus
est-ce qu'il va rester trois saisons
plus haut à paris sa sur pour comparer
aux 6 à thann par exemple ibrahimovic à
pauleta selatan est resté quand même
quatre saisons il a marqué 133 buts avec
le club de la capitale est ce que
finalement c'est pas un plus impactants
peut-être stéphane koechlin pauleta
finalement il a il a gagné il a tout
gagné avec paris sauf la ligue des
champions movies touche pauleta c'est
deux joueurs bien différent
pauleta y travaille pour l'équipe et
c'est un peu un pays sans un regard des
excuses adressées par les supporters bon
c'est pour ça parce qu'il se bat il se
bat il se bat et pas ils se battent et
il marqué des super but c'est souvent
lui qui donnait la victoire à paris
quand le match était serré ou bloqués
pauleta était là et branoux ibrahimovic
était plus j'ai pas je suis ibrahimovic
c'est autre chose
louise bourgoin restera pas dans le
coeur des parisiens simplement que parce
que depuis qu'il est parti de paris mais
il a craché sur le club
c'est à partir de ce moment-là il il n'a
jamais eu le l'écusson grave est gravé
dans nos gravé dans les annales
à partir de ce moment là vous pouvez pas
continuer de d'aduler ou de supporter un
joueur qui tiens voilà qui tient à ce
que neymar a déjà commencé à faire en
plus alors qu'il y en a pietilae un
petit peu le maillot alors qu'il est il
est encore est ce que j'entends le
caractère on l'a vu dans les interviews
pauleta ses idoles mais les supporters
qui étaient présents insisté sur le
caractère la gentillesse de pauleta qui
allait souvent les voies est ce que
c'est ça aussi qui fait la différence
entre un grand joueur et une idole
complet qu'on voulait c'est l'état
d'esprit le
l'humanité et la proximité qu'il a quand
même gardé pendant ces 5 saisons malgré
malgré ses performances malgré son
récent succès et il le dit lui il est
tout autre c'est une c'est une histoire
qui dure avec le avec le psg la tan n'a
jamais fait l'effort de parler en
français
oui mais ces voix là vous prenez il est
resté un peu moins longtemps soit pas en
france je capable est à peu près le
gardien allemand vous me rappelez son
nom qui est arrivé et qui est reparti
une trappe
kevin trappe au bout de trois mois il
parlait en français quand il est en
interview je veux dire ce soit
voilà c'est juan à leur niveau ils ont
les moyens techniques d'apprendre une
langue très rapidement de pouvoir se
l'approprier et de pouvoir parler en
comment et puis on n'est pas obligé de
faire des objets qu'ils avaient des
grands discours mais simplement pouvoir
répondre en francis lalanne n'a jamais
dit un mot en français
voilà c'est quand même je pense que
c'est les générations télé c'est à dire
avec ses terrasses on est on voit là où
on est dans l'image plutôt
d'individualisme et vraiment prédominant
je trouve maintenant dans le football
alors que pauleta était je trouve un
faisait partie de la dernière génération
des des bons ouvriers quelque part
malgré malgré leur niveau supérieur on
voit les on voit des performances
individuelles on voit des joueurs mieux
jouer que dans les décennies antérieures
ça c'est sûr mais je trouve parfois en
regardant des vieux match que le jeu
collectif et certaines passes sont plus
impressionnantes que celles qu'on voit
maintenant
maintenant on voit beaucoup de dribbles
et quasiment des effets spéciaux des
acrobates en fin de compte mais je
trouve que le jeu collectif perd 2,2
sont sublimés et voilà après ce n'est
peut-être pas forcément la même époque
aussi au niveau de l'image par rapport
aux transferts mais clairement les
joueurs à rester beaucoup plus longtemps
dans les clubs
alors que maintenant
voilà contraint coup c'est ça les
joueurs moi un peu plus souvent jouer
sur la case transferts on va dire pour
augmenter leurs salaires
c'est peut-être ça aussi pierre
chevallier sait faire jouer un petit peu
l'argent l'argent roi et c'est
sportivement ça me fait penser
finalement à cette évolution du parlé en
disant que c'est sportivement c'est
devenu des matchs de playstation et et
on est en termes après 2 d'histoire
d'histoire humaine c'est ch et parce que
parce que désormais il ya d'énormes
enjeux financiers et qu'il faut c'est la
course à l'armement
c'est pour ça que c'est pour ça qu'on
parle de plus en plus de débats paix à
madrid et de neymar de retour au barça
est ce qu'est ce que c'est ces artistes
si on peut les appeler comme ça au moins
deux au moins deux occasions de marquer
l'empreinte de leur empreinte le club
comme l'a fait pauleta au psg parce que
justement c'était pas n'étaient pas les
mêmes donnent c'est pas les mêmes
d'exigence est finalement maintenant
c'est dans la culture de l'instantané
faut être performant tout de suite vous
disais tout à l'heure que l'importance
pour un attaquant notamment c'est de
marquer beaucoup de buts
je crois que c'est aussi son attachement
et sa vie avec le club et puis et puis
finalement aussi des titres les titres
qui vont aller chercher ça sera toujours
plus marquants d'aller chercher une
première ligue des champions pour paris
que 12 coupe de france ça le mot de la
fin sur cette thématique on passe
maintenant être pas je débats
[Musique]
dans cette rubrique débats je vous
propose aujourd'hui une sélection à des
sportifs ou des événements qui ont
marqué l'année à 2019 parmi les top on
retrouve un pistard quentin à lafargue
le sportif licencié au vélo club
elancourt saint quentin en yvelines a
remporté trois titres majeurs cette
saison dont un titre de champion du
monde du kilomètre on écoute les
réactions micro de tv 70 est très belle
saison 2010 9 sur laquelle physiquement
j'ai montré que la progression qu'en fin
suivait son cours et est en tout cas qui
donne beaucoup de confiance pour la
suite ça faisait quelques années qui
tournait autour ou un peu autour du cou
et je dirais que cette année elle a été
l'année de la consécration de de cantat
mais ça fait quand même quelques années
qu'on sent que planter un peu faire des
grands résultats cette table est ce que
quand à la farq est un top sur cette
année à 2019 oui oui oui d'accord bien
déjà rayé ou qu'il connaissait bien
oui bien sûr ça fait très plaisir il
fait aussi partie du top 10 des joueurs
français par l'augmentation de la chaîne
eurosport etc paraissait pistards
français
non non non il fait partie des sportifs
français est arrivé 10e 10e dans le top
10 de ce classement
ce qui est très très bien pour un
pistard il faut pas oublier que l'année
où françois pervis a été à guérir 3 3 3
titres de champion du monde
il n'a même pas été élu vélo d'or ii
vélo d'or français enfin vélo d'or
mondiale donc qu un pistard puisse
intégrer ce classement toutes
disciplines confondues
c'est vraiment très très bien et donc
ensuite qu'il soit reconnu dans les
yvelines on sait c'est tout à fait
normal je suis un peu déçu c'est ne pas
faire partie du classement
mais il y avait un kyste à redon
complète élections on a évité mais met
donc donc non rs et c'est amplement
mérité parce que en plus c'est un c'est
un garçon qui donne énormément
juste avant de venir à l'émission je
suis passé je suis passé au vélodrome et
tous les mercredis après midi il y a le
la section cycliste d'un d'un colonel
d'un collège dans coin qui vient faire
des entraînements et quentin était là
aujourd'hui pour animer pour animer la
séance
donc voilà il il donne en plus à avec
grande grande sympathie aussi bien aux
abonnés que qu'aux jeunes qu'aux jeunes
du département
et ça c'est quelque chose qu'on ne lui
enlèvera jamais et que voilà il fait
vivre le sport et je voyais je suis
arrivé sur la fin de la séance
donc du coup c'était le petit moment des
photos bas les gamins étaient aussi
contents de pouvoir faire des photos
avec avec quentin lafargue que les
supporters de paris avec pedro miguel
pauleta
c'est la même chose pour nous pour nous
pistard et pour nous cycliste voilà
c'est tout c'est notre star c'est notre
star duel hélène le côté sportif et
beauté aux matières personnel qui se
rejoignent vous en pensez quoi je trouve
ça parfait ça a rejoint
certaines ont sûrement vous ouais
faisons mais non mais c'est un jour ce
qu'on disait avec pauleta en fait cet
esprit un peu ça me partage etc etc pour
le club mais en même temps je fais des
performances et je trouve que c'est il a
tout compris
il est jeune mais il est dans cette
dynamique qu'on aime le sport et je
trouve que c'est parfait qui reste comme
ça q longtemps possible ce sera ça sera
très bien
raul l'a 29 ans est ce qu'il peut encore
progresser selon vous j'imagine qu'à cet
âge là oui surtout surtout quand on a
déjà un titre de champion du monde
il serait en train d'entamer des
inférences comme ça et je pense qu'il a
peut-être un avantage qui m'a marqué
c'est la première fois que je vois soit
une équipe soit un sportif tout court
masculin a entraîné par une femme et ça
ça me ça m'a pas laissé indifférent
voilà c'est la première fois que doit
s'intituler où je me demande si
justement ça sera pas sans plus je ne me
prononcerai pas sur le sujet
non je me prononce pas sur le sujet soit
au sénat alors 2020 saura-t-elle une
année encore plus belles à votre avis
pour pour quentin lafargue pierre
chevallier
il y a les chances des géométries sion
le kilomètre n'est pas aux jo
voilà la compétition chez les juniors
les autres ont fait j'ai réagi niant les
échéances qu'il ya ce que les
championnats de champion du monde
championnat dehors quand même c'était un
championnat de france seniors 100 km
donc tu auras pas il y aura pas d mois
sont aussi riches que ça chaque année
s'ils ont plus à tokyo il n'y a pas de
ya pas de kilomètres donc enfin sûrement
remplacé par l'équipe donc non priori ça
sera pas aussi riche que 2019 mais
peut-être avec une médaille aux ânes
étape olympique a nommé cette année il y
aura encore championnat de france
championnat du monde et j'appelle à doha
fin plus léger ou cette année les
pistards on en rajoute une mais pas un
kilo mais pas de kilomètres et
kilomètres quand il fera la vitesse par
équipes et la vitesse par équipes il
surmonte pas encore décidé si on n'est
pas content lafargue le meilleur
km/heure au troisième tour en plus ben
oui c'est toujours le problème des jeux
olympiques normalement on peut mettre
quatre gars et là où je voulais c'est
quoi ton différent on peut rester sur
trois en effet il est en concurrence
avec michael d'almeida
c'est vrai que c'est dommage parce qu'on
a on a deux très très bons éléments sur
le sur le troisième tour le là où
l'équipe de france pêche aujourd'hui sur
la vitesse par équipes s'est c'est sur
le départ on a une grosse inverse un
gros déficit sur le sur le premier tour
même si grégory baugé fait tout son
possible pour être pour être au niveau
mais là l'isoler les néo-zélandais et
les les
hollandais sont beaucoup trop fort on
prend une seconde on est la deuxième
nation en vitesse par équipes un
surclassement lci sauf que à chaque
compétition on prend une seconde parlée
par les hollandais sur trois tours c'est
phénoménal c'est incroyable donc
donc c'est très très compliqué de
pouvoir de pouvoir combler 7,7 secondes
un autre sportif qui a marqué l'année
andy cabreira avila sur ce plateau c'est
ta playlist qui est maître qui était sur
ce plateau sur l'heure du 7-8 sport cet
analyste qui est maître nageur à la
piscine de saint cyr l'école a enchaîné
cette année les records les compétitions
il a notamment réalisé un record d'apnée
en le respirant que 4 minutes et 12
secondes en six heures et tout cela pour
la bonne cause c'était pour sensibiliser
le grand public sur la maltraitance des
animaux dans les parcs aquatiques nous
l'avions reçu donc sur le 7-8 sport
c'est un accord inédit parce que
personne jamais a fait ça est simple et
manche entre des régions spécifiques à
pouvoir donner son souffle et pour les
millions d'inscrits des fois les
tendances pis il était inférieur à une
seconde
45e il ya quatre kilomètres heure qui
comme nous met les moments que les
ruches la vocation de l'oriental
voilà pendant six heures c'est l'eau
mais c'est faisable qu'on a la
conviction pour une belle cause
il a également participé aux
championnats du monde d'apnée à
villefranche sur mer cet été en
représentant cuba est-ce que andy
cabreira à villa est un top sur cette
année vu ses performances
je pense que la question voilà je sais
pas ce que vous en pensez
ça c'est pour contrarier d'accord vous
voulez contrarier factuel non mais j'y
connais rien donc d'accord faisait
qu'est ce que vous en pensez du coût de
cette performance
moi je trouve que c'est exceptionnel
c'est quatre minutes et 12 secondes 1
c'est exceptionnel sur six heures c'est
exceptionnel c'est tout ce que j'ai à
dire
chevallier je suis partagé entre le
entre la performance humaine
en avait déjà parlé sur ce plateau là la
performance humaine d'une part de
deuxièmement la cause qu'il défend
auquel il sensibilise et enfin le côté
un peu anecdotique qui te laisses de la
discipline malheureusement
ça reste s'arrête une performance
humaine peut-être sportive d'ailleurs
quel que soit le point de vue auquel on
se place de la sur le côté expositions
et puis et puis performance performance
médiatique j'allais dire je veux un
petit peu partagé donc ça me marque - le
l'humain mais mise à part ça me marque
moins qu'une une moisson de médailles
comme celle de quentin lafarge ya des
gens qui est un spécialiste date n'est
pas vraiment mais non mais je suis
toujours vraiment impressionné par pas
cette performance
j'ai la chance de côtoyer xavier dépit
qui est aussi appelée east et qui a été
médaillé de bronze au championnat du
monde
et donc quand on voyage peut échanger
avec lui et c'est un c'est un ami et
c'est vrai que quand tu peux échanger
avec lui et donc voir 7,7 performante de
rappeler mois son prénom handicap et la
voilà au lait voilà ce que ça vous
pourrez vous leur demandez dix fois on
dit donc c'est vrai que moi je reste
impressionné par ce que parce que c'est
quand même long 6 heures un trail un
trail de course à pied quand on attaque
c'est ce type de ce type d'effort sont
des vrais vraie préparation et donc que
ce soit six heures sur une selle d'un
cheval que ce soit six heures sur un
terrain de rugby ou six heures à courir
sur une piste d'athlé ma quelle que soit
la discipline appartient le monde arrive
dans ces longues heures d'efforts il ya
vraiment quelque chose de très
respectables voilà jeu
je trouve ça je trouve ça vraiment
vraiment vraiment très bon on va
continuer à parler d'apnée injustement
yann je sais vous êtes passionné par ce
sujet avec un autre top l'apesi oise
julie un peu joue 30 ans a remporté cet
été le concours de miss sirène à france
et oui vous avez bien entendu ces
disciplines éviter original mélange à la
fois le sport et la beauté objectif pour
retenir sa respiration avec un costume
de sirène alors emporté cette épreuve
face à huit candidates et c'est un vrai
sport car elle s'entraîne plusieurs fois
par semaine à la piscine des
clayes-sous-bois en l'écoutant je
m'attendais pas du tout à gagner pas du
tout j'étais allée ont plutôt en mode
plutôt défi personnel
voulait vivre aussi une expérience avec
d'autres sirènes parce que c'est pas
tous les jours que l'on peut rencontrer
des sirènes en france c'est un top ou
pas pour voter comment on parle du tour
de table alors qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
si les fans l'habitat désirons français
voilà attise la méfiance % pour sa
course à la peau sympa sont absents plus
en plus mais sans plus raul a fallu le
début d'après me suis seulement que je
pouvais la sphère monte en amazone
assise à gauche va écouter
je vous passe à son numéro après
l'émission sera un volet volontiers
alors qu'est ce que vous en pensez
non mais je trouve que c'est c'est
comment dirais-je c'est surprenant
surprenant maintenant effectivement pour
aller encore plus dans le sens de pur
mais l'image justement pourrait décider
si oui ou non voilà
on peut pas dire que c'est une
performance sportive qui marque qui
marquent l'année à proprement parler si
on est là pour parler de sport
sérieusement on sort un petit peu du
contexte
hélène je rejoins ce que dijon s'est pas
voilà je vais pas dire que c'est un top
c'est pas non plus flop no qu après
voilà c'est c'est quelque chose de sympa
mais on n'est pas dans une performance
de haut niveau il n'y a pas d'énorme
compétition avec beaucoup de grâce dans
l'eau en fait mon boulot mais je veux
dire à la limite on n'est pas je serai
plus impressionné de voir de la natation
synchronisée par exemple c'est beau mais
en fait le costume fait beaucoup les
positions sont beaucoup voient c'est le
photographe il faut ça fait beaucoup
ça fait non mais ces deux là voilà c'est
quelque chose plutôt d'artistique pour
moi que de sortie c'est comme si on sait
comme s'ils ont récompensé le champion
de france de pole dance c'est pareil son
rêve en tout cas c'est de faire partie
d'un mac au royaume pour pouvoir se
produire
et elle veut participer à miss merveille
de monde qui se tiendra en egypte en
début d'année 2020 sacré
un sacré événement sa porte mon nom mais
pour le coup c'est comme si non comment
ça vous intéresse c'est fou ya des
disciplines pas des noms mais s'il ya
des épreuves c'est pas des trucs imposé
ou
il faut voir vraiment commencé à
organiser mais là comme ça celle qui me
fait nous fait ce sont des sirènes
attention mais comment qu'elle ait des
poissons voilà excusez-moi de mister
triton oui alors je vous propose
maintenant un dernier à top l'open de
france de golf au mois d'octobre dernier
l'événement a une nouvelle fois était
organisée au golf national à guyancourt
et c'est le belge nicolas colsaerts qui
remporte la compétition cette année en
l'écoutant de joueurs voilà ça fait ça
fait 18 ans que je suis pro j'ai gagné
deux fois j'allais gagner plus souvent
comme je l'aï déjà dit souvent le fait
de gagner chez vous c'est génial j'ai
joué un peu l'impression de faire partie
du paysage golfique français alors
l'événement a été plutôt une réussite
sur le plan sportif avec une belle
compétition avec sept victoires que de
colsaerts mais l'événement n'a pas
attiré les foules seulement 24 mille
personnes sont venues sur le site contre
48 mille l'année précédente
top ou pas top selon son côté sportif on
peut dire que ça va bon pour vous c'est
un top 1 pour vous à dire chevallier
c'est un top c'est un flop sur
l'organisation et c'est un top sur pour
deux raisons premièrement parce que
c'est comme sartre parce que c'est le
plus français des belges et que c'est
donc un francophone la régie ne me
contredira pas et
c'est un beau champion ils s'entraînent
ils s'entraînent depuis des années avec
les français il est pote avec tout le
monde
quand il vient en france il profite de
tout de tout ce qui a de tout ce qui est
son quotidien a profité j'ai des copains
restaurateur à versailles qui
l'accueille à bras ouverts donc c'est un
beau champion et c'est un top parce que
la fédération française de golf n'a pas
eu le choix dans la date et a dû a dû
composer avec une date imposée en
octobre fin octobre et a quand même
réussi malgré tout un an après la ryder
cup
un an après un open de france qui avait
réuni les foules à sortir une
compétition a même eu de la chance il
n'a pas fait trop trop mauvais il a fait
froid mais pas trop trop mauvais donc vu
les circonstances
bravo la cedh est d'avoir réussi quand
même à sortir l'open de france dans des
circonstances un type délicate et avec
un beau champion non je suis c'est ce
que j'avais dit finalement que c'était
pas si mal que ça comme résultat par
avec les circonstances etc
mais ça n'empêche que avec le recul avec
le recul ça reste un club stéphane roman
le golf j'adhère pas vous adhérez pas
maintenant ça vous plaît pas non non non
est-ce que j'ai eu l'occasion d'essayer
je suis allé au golf national j'ai
essayé mais je crois j'adhère pas non
c'est pas votre chance pour montrer sur
l'événement est ce que c'est un flop
pour vous avez voté flop pas top en tout
cas non parce que mon jour
alors va continuer cette émission par
les flops de cette année 2010 9 on
commence par du football américain les
templiers d'elancourt ont calé une
nouvelle fois en playoffs de deuxième
division elles ont été battues par les
gladiateurs de la queue en brie en
demi-finale sur le score de 15 à 10
conséquence cette défaite condamne les
élans courtois rester une année de plus
en deuxième division ce sera donc la
reprise au mois de janvier une quatrième
saison consécutive en d2 des
contre-performances qui devrait peser
sur le budget financier du club on
écoute la réaction du coach
en fait c'est nous qui donnons le match
on se tire des balles dans le pied en
fait tout simplement on a un problème
d'attitude de fautes répétées qui
qui nous qui nous pourrissent la vie
depuis depuis quelques années il faut
vraiment qu'on règle le problème parce
que parce que c'est c'est trop triste
d'avoir un potentiel comme le nôtre est
de la voir des résultats en fait si vous
aussi mauvais on va voter flop ou pas
flop selon un flop pour vous il a mis
fin pour moi ou je sais pas encore
pourquoi ben parce que j'ai l'impression
que c'est les contre performances sont
les raisons de problèmes dont ils ont la
conscience
donc c'est d'autant plus ce d'autant
plus rageant quand un problème
s'explique et qui se répète quand même
pour moi c'est la situation d'autant
plus grave
c'est pour ça que je pense que c'est un
flap aux annonces avant le début du
championnat sur le même plateau de dano
place où ils avaient dit qu'ils allaient
battre tout le monde avec 50 points et
dès le premier match ils ont été battus
de justesse
donc du coup ils avaient réussi à gagner
ils ont pas été du coup plus humbles sur
le reste de la saison
ils ont gagné pas mal de leur match mais
voilà encore une fois il rate la montée
alors que c'était l'objectif affiché est
même plus qu'affichée donc en effet
maintenant on peut leur souhaiter qu'une
chose c'est de
dedans finalement réussir à monter mais
en effet plus les années passent et plus
ça va devenir compliqué parce que ben
ouais le budget budget ne suit plus donc
donc là ça va ça va ça va devenir urgent
justement stéphane est ce que ça va
devenir compliqué les temps payer ils
ont eu un gros niveau
il était en coupe d'europe il est
entonné des chants de football champion
d'europe
ils n'ont pas été champions d'europe
mais par contre ils ont été en ligue des
champions league des chiffres jusqu'en
demi finale de ligue des champions voilà
je sais que depuis je suis j'habite ment
pas j'ai toujours entendu parler des
templiers
donc là les voir en seconde division
s'est passé pendant de très nombreuses
années en première division et le souci
c'est que ben forcément le budget de
départ en 2e division ça prive les
landes courtois de deux bons matches à
elancourt quoi il ya également lu trois
changements de présidents en un an et
lui georges agostino qui restent pendant
trois ans et maintenant 30 ans pardon et
maintenant c'est christine bloggie
baranger qui prend la suite après joël
da silva manque de stabilité peut être
aussi au sein du club pierre chevallier
structuration de structuration
organisation les ambitions qui change
avec chaque arrivée de nouveaux georges
actuellement vers en tant que président
alors parfois parfois le changement peut
avoir du bon de l'histoire nous l'a nous
l'a prouvé mais
c'est savoir si les uns et les autres à
deir aux différents projets qui arrivent
dans les valises des nouveaux présidents
et présidentes et on en a souvent parlé
je crois que c'est une question d'abord
d'état d'esprit de l'équipe
oui effectivement ça dès le début de
cette saison là ça manquait cruellement
de d'humilité et ils sont ils sont pris
le retour de boomerang à s'éviter et
parmi eux peut-être pas par manque que
par manque d'abnégation plus que de
conscience le lien accord avec raul
c'est c'est assez étonnant de les voir
des voir rater cette saison là comme les
précédentes dernier flop
on termine par du football focus sur
trappe le club est montée en régionale 2
cette année pour la première fois de son
histoire en juin dernier avec hicham
azer dit vous allez me dire que c'est un
top mais finalement non echams r&d
quitte le club pour raisons personnelles
ludovic gauthier en provenance de
versailles le remplace la mayonnaise ne
prend pas tout de suite il est
finalement remplacé dès le mois de
novembre après un début de saison
catastrophique on écoute le président de
trappes ces sports qui font le lit nos
vies gauthier il ya des compétences il
est diplômé et voilà il a fait des clubs
le pet qui l'a fait versailles il est
même monté l'année dernière comme nous
avec son équipe de versailles peut il
arriver champions donc il est mon temps
et r2 donc l'équipe aider dans notre
groupe donc là dessus il ya aucun aucun
problème avec lui sur ses compétences
son management tout voilà c'est plutôt
le le résultat sportif qui a fait que le
club a pris cette décision
le club de trappes arrive finalement à
convaincre
hicham et redit de revenir et depuis le
club ne perd plus que le temps que de
temps perdu le flop c'est donc l'erreur
de casting avec le choix de ludovic
gauthier ce que c'est vraiment un flop
vraiment ce choix d'entraîneur non pas
vraiment et ce non pas du tout enjoy non
parce que rapidement mais je trouve que
c'est un rapidement aux musulmans
on pourra simplement dire à la fin de la
saison si ça a été un flop
la c voila voila faux départ je pense
qu'au contraire ils ont été rapidement
réactifs ils ont rapidement trouvé les
solutions pour faire en sorte que la
situation puisse se redresser pour moi
je pense que la gestion la gestion du
club est très saine et très et ça aurait
pu être un très bon pari donc ya pas de
pas de réseau cette femme très
rapidement garage il ya les résultats
qui suivent donc pour l'instant donc
pour l'instant voilà ils sont dixièmes
sur 12 équipes engagées en régionale 2
ils ont une dynamique de deux victoires
et deux nuls en quatre matches depuis la
reprise
bien sûr ça va le faire selon vous
pierre chevalier lui faire c'est sa faux
départ un faux départ il
ils sont rendus compte de leur erreur
ils ont ils ont corrigé il est une
solution il était parti pour raisons
personnelles
oui oui on enlever 1000 évolué on avait
aussi un film et ils vont ils vont se
maintenir sans aucun problème ce qui
était peut-être déjà l'objectif quand on
quand on est après une montée donc en r2
sait très bien comment alors je vous
propose maintenant de revivre tous les
moments forts qui ont rythmé le paysage
sportif yves binois cette année regardé
et on débrief après
[Musique]
je pense même pas neuf il dit je revis a
scellé med mais technique
se déplacer c'était très plaisant de
gagner aujourd'hui aussi d'obtenir le
maillot jaune
ce sera sympa de le porter ce maillot
jaune demain aujourd'hui c'était une
étape très dure avec beaucoup de vent
mais l'équipe a fait du très bon travail
avec six coureurs dans le premier groupe
[Musique]
ya beaucoup de choses que vous vous en
doutez sont inscrits
ici j'ai ma force de volonté
la magie du quidditch c'est pouvoir
mélanger plusieurs sports pour retenir
nouveau et après on est sur des
manipulations de balles sur du dodge
ball à en année américain on est sûre
d'elle même manipulation du ballon de
volée super cette première place qu'ils
ont occupé les trois quarts de l'année
ça fait vraiment plaisir tout le mérite
en revient aux joueurs au staff aussi
kim a un qui m'accompagne la direction
qui m'a fait confiance cette année est
vraiment fier aussi de terminer
meilleure défense de la ligue de paris
[Musique]
mais là
ces coeurs
enfin
sûrement
tous les actes qu'ils font
ça me donne des idées
la compétition approche plus plus
agrandi pour iliad effervescence donc
c'est bien pour nous c'est positif pour
les enfants ils sont pleins d'énergie
donc on en prend c'est bien
c'est toujours valorisant d'être sur un
terrain de faire partager ce que ces
notes parce qu'ils a permis de gagner
pas mal de titres
[Musique]
les plus du français était la criée
encore et encore et je me suis dit il
faut que j'aille tant que geste et j'ai
poussé dans les bols s'est passé c'est
juste incroyable d'avoir gagné ici je
suis enfin sorti du salar de uyuni j'ai
rejoint la terre les cailloux de sa
sortie aux coudes surtout celles parce
que j'en avais marre d'avoir les fesses
toutes blanches à cause de ça donc voilà
c'est la fin de cette aventure
après 140 km parcouru six jours de
solitude donc des airs
c'est que du bonheur c'est
l'aboutissement de huit mois de travail
pour
mais l'équipe high tone naturellement et
bien une centaine une bonne centaine de
bénévoles
effectivement c'est du bonheur parce que
on va enfin vivre cette journée à
rambouillet tant attendu pour les rambos
littamé pour le territoire et pour
beaucoup de visiteurs
je m'attendais pas du tout à gagner pas
du tout j'étais allée ont plutôt en mode
auto défi personnel
voulait vivre aussi une expérience avec
d'autres sirènes parce que c'est pas
tous les jours que l'on peut rencontrer
des sirènes en france
c'est très rare de les avoir c'est vrai
en france parce qu'ils voyagent déjà un
fou qui se déplace et on les a déjà eu
deux trois ans et c'est vrai que c'est
très rare qui viennent et c'est vraiment
exceptionnel de les avoir en français
[Musique]
je pense que mon niveau même toute la
semaine était très bon
donc
je savais que je pouvais bien joué ici
parce que j'avais dit je l'avais déjà
fait l'année passée j'avais gagné ici
aussi donc je me sentais bien je me sens
très confiant
m
c'est mythique
c'est une des courses des 4,5 course
mythique en france et puis on est loin
du coin ou versailles on court en pleine
campagne mais c'est pas un trade
c'est difficile mais à l'arrivée on est
toujours satisfait
[Musique]
c'est énormément de joueurs voilà ça
fait ça fait 18 ans que je suis pro j'ai
gagné deux fois j'aurais dû gagner plus
souvent comme je l'aï déjà dit souvent
elle fait de gagner chez vous c'est
génial j'ai joué un peu l'impression de
faire partie du paysage golfique
français
ça me plaît parce que voilà j'ai des
anecdotes aussi dans mon passé qui m'ont
permis de rencontrer des champions je
m'en souviens ça m'a marqué je m'en suis
servi on va faire un rapide tour de
table quel évènement vous a marqué cette
année en 2019
stéphane si vous deviez retenir un
événement la création d'un club de
basket fauteuil au chesnay versailles
je trouve que philippe femme a fait un
travail excellent j'ai adhéré à ce
projet ça fait venir beaucoup de gens et
on s'amuse permis à julie bravo et je
dis encore que si beaucoup de personnes
en situation de handicap veulent
rejoindre le club
ils sont les bienvenus les entraînements
c'est le lundi et biya le hand fauteuil
aussi comme on en avait parlé
la fois dernière en fauteuil à mon team
bretonne fini le bretonneux on a noté
tout ça raul un événement moi c'est les
deux les deux venus de grandes stars
dans des clubs donner des master class
au judo et en natation alain bernard
oui alain bernard et puis le mais moi je
trouve ça fabuleux quand on peut offrir
aux sportifs
moi ça m'est déjà arrivé quand j'étais
plus jeune et c'est des moments qu'on
n'oublie jamais donc quand ils font
parfois l'effort de venir dans les
yvelines c'est génial pierre chevallier
rapidement l'équipe de france féminine
encore basés en entraînement dans les
yvelines
parce que c'était une belle une belle
année pour le foot féminin notamment
l'exposition médiatique même si elle
perd contre les américaines et et qui ne
sont pas allées suffisamment loin en
coupe du monde mais c'était c'est déjà
un beau clin d'oeil et les 10 secondes
les com
raul tout ce qui est ce ta rien voilà
les mercis d'ars des transmissions le
fait de faire partager les gens du riant
des cinq secondes où le premier type de
grand dans la farine de champion du
monde
voilà pour moi c'est faire partie des
monuments de cette année le top de
l'année 2019 pour yann dujarrier jugé en
octobre
alors on va terminer comme d'habitude
par une citation aujourd'hui je vous
propose de terminer par une citation de
l'ancien pilote de formule 1 mika
hakkinen pour faire un bon vainqueur il
faut être un bon perdant
je vous laisse méditer sur cette phrase
à bientôt sur tb 78 excellente fête de
fin d'année
[Musique]
oui